alright well let's talk about let's talk
about a couple other a couple other the
policy things I was sort of disappointed
that the NSA have you heard about this
situation we're going to get to it
several times later on the show uh it
only got about two lines and they were
sort of throwaway lines it was really
really nothing has he really just gotten
off the hook with the NSA thing it's it
seems like he sort of has come out of
this unscathed like he didn't know about
it kind of thing it's gonna I think it's
gonna eventually gloss over i missed the
two points when you said he's missin
twice i remember when those no one
thought but just in it two sentences in
a row and then that's all senses yet so
there you go right you know that we
talked about this little on the point
last week i think that for most people
the NSA thing they're sort of horrified
to hear about it but at the same time
they've kind of resigned themselves the
fact that there's no privacy left in
this internet world and that the
government is always kind of pulling the
sword shanigan so i don't know that it's
that it has an outrage that sticks here
a new thing your office terrible and
then you did doesn't yeah and speaking
about we're gonna get to one of the new
things in a segment shortly uh you know
i was thinking last night during some of
this that you know is in a way does he
have to come off at the end of his two
terms as a bit of a disappointment no
matter what he does because he came in
on hope and change in this amazing thing
we're gonna change the world and change
the system and if you watch that thing
last night it's just it's just a
politician like at the end of the day he
really is just a politician so did we
all sort of real kind of delusional uh
for those first years no matter what he
accomplishes this year just kept the
first campaign I I guess the first
campaign we all sort of delusional in
this ID in this really incredible idea
uh more than now it's he's in it and
he's a politician what we think we kind
of always will because no one knows at
least us outside of the whole bubble
knows what gets said and what gets done
and why to the fullest extent why these
guys do what they do I mean he came in
he was the picture of the change that
would help doesn't help to yeah if if an
old white guy comes in and says I got
hoping I've got change will say oh he's
got hope but I'll see any change in like
embodiment yeah embodied what he was
saying so much that it was hard not to
get caught up with it so once we once
there's a circle of disappointment and
not doing everything we expected
based on my said they're like we still
make any sense we he just like in many
ways just like a lot of the others and
that's where it comes from yeah and
that's what I mean that the idea was so
big that no matter what he would have
done that in a way UK the system isn't
change money isn't out of politics those
kind yeah III think that sometimes
people get too excited about took up you
know look if Kennedy had not been shot
that had made it through to terms that
would have been the same sense of like
oh well he's not you know he's immortal
you know and I think in this area he's a
mortal's own thing and I think the same
with Obama side yeah he does not live to
the sort of crazy expectations that we
had in 2008 but we were also coming off
of you know eight years of a horror and
I think that in the historical
perspective you know look at the bikini
graph look at whatever else you to sort
of look at the concrete accomplishments
this administration um yeah even if that
that that burst of enthusiasm didn't pay
off we're still gonna look back on
somebody who really got us out of a
terrible terrible place economically
speaking globally speaking in a lot of
ways you gave us a little hope and
change bow on that I like that and
finally we should talk about the
Republican rebuttal cathy McMorris
Rodgers she gave the official GOP
rebuttal on a very stiff couch that was
my main take away from it Mike Lee gave
the Tea Party rebuttal Rand Paul gave
the independent report or it was the red
it was just the rand paul i'm in a
nuclear bunker i can't be hit by a drone
here rebuttal and then uh John Boehner
gave a six-second vine rebuttal um did
that even just show what a joke the
Republicans are that they had literal
and I think there was still another one
that I'm forgetting uh or there was a
Spanish one familiar Ross Layton um
which is all that's all fine but my
point being that it's such a frayed
party that even their rebuttals which of
course our pre written so they're not
even responding to what was just uh what
was just said that they all just seemed
sort of canned and and ridiculous what I
notice from the official the one of the
sama sama vessel ones there are so they
can Captain Rogers it becomes a I don't
when I was looking to it becomes a
coming out speech so I don't know we're
not that kind but never about exactly
where I'm not sure what other aspiration
she has but when you start giving you
back
you know my mom did this and my father
that and I would causes this and my son
has Down syndrome my daughter's awesome
just 18 weeks ago sick get to state of
union yep instead it's just becomes a
small campaign speech about how awesome
she is and how American she is and how
you should support her and I feel like
that's gonna be the next step I'm not
sure she's trying to go with this well
yeah I go one level the it's it's a way
for the party be like check this person
al but it's been you know what I think
having us check out you know bobby
Jindal was but big mistake and I I think
every year it sort of why I think it's
become the who gets the short straw you
private before people probably clamored
for but it is that that that spot has a
curse on it now I think that's actually
a really great point because so they
thought bobby Jindal is going to be the
next star and his rebuttal is a disaster
then Marco Rubio last year was the
watergate beyond disaster